you know what I love about this is that
this is very practical it's not like
this magic bullet answer no it sounds to
me like it was it was a lot of hard work
to get out and that's Josh and I we talk
about that a lot how you know simple
isn't necessarily easy yes easy is to
get into debt to go with the flow and
then eventually you know you end up with
the waterfall and regretting it right um
but but yes - to simplify your life to
get out of debt it takes a lot of work
it takes a plan and I'll tell you man
anyone out there right now in this this
crowd or listening to this podcast who
is struggling with finances you've got
to start with a budget like that is by
far the number one thing since we're on
the road with Anthony and Chris and
Rachel I've been like you know going
over all these financial books and
there's one very common thing through
every book it is start with a budget so
now I have like a little mentoring a
side business that I have we're all
taking on some some mentoring students
and stuff and the students will come to
me and they they'll talk about their
money problems yeah and it might be ten
minutes into the call and I'm like I'm
happy to spend this whole hour with you
but have a budget and then let's talk
about your money problems after you come
up with a budget and it was like this is
like you don't have a money problem if
you have a budget problem right yeah you
have the budget right exactly then we'll
talk about the money
yeah and it's it's just um I had no idea
how because I went on the budget before
when I was trying to get out of debt
right and then you know as soon as I was
out of debt I just kind of slacked off a
little bit on the budget and after going
through these books I'm talking to
Mariah because we live in LA now and
it's a little bit more expensive to live
in LA the Montana clearly yeah and I'm
like I'm like you know what we were
doing so much better than our finances
in Montana another were livin in a light
like we need to come up with a budget so
we've been doing this for the last
couple months and man every time that I
I might go to the corner store want to
buy like sparkling water or something
and it cost me three bucks and the
thought of going to the Sorbonne is
paying the $3.00 and then going into my
every dollar app to put in the three
dollars I spent it's not worth the
hassle of messing with my budget so just
having that one little tool it is really
puts your spending into perspective
yeah and to keep this in mind I have the
opportunity when y'all hit the road with
Chris Hogan he can definitely
some more but I've had the opportunity
to wear for my mentors and millionaires
and and I've asked them all the same
thing how did you get there how did you
do it what do you what is one tip would
you give me to be a millionaire and none
of them really knew at the time and I
was connected with Dave and stuff like
that and all of them said have a budget
you